when the first lockdown hit do you get
stuck in america
yeah i got stuck in him and i i don't i
find america quite hard sometimes
because i'm very
english and i would just like to say you
saved my life when i was in america
seriously swear to god i was like i was
missing fish and chips
i was missing pints a lager like people
in hollywood they're not very like got
british humor average i mean you can't
tell someone in hollywood the feet stink
they'll still be like you'll just look
at yourself funny it's like
it's like it's like even if someone's
feet stink in america it's like oh my
god hi
like your feet are amazing i mean
i was sat in the aisles bingeing peep
show
yeah i mean ma'am to send me chocolate
hobnobs across the ocean
wanting to get home alan bennett in 50
[Laughter]
years
very glad i was able to help destroy the
whole hollywood vibe
you just burned that it was just like
you just like
i loved it
you